Наші найкращі класичні суперкомп'ютери стають дедалі потужнішими,
і ми все краще справляємося з обчисленнями, зокрема з моделюванням систем.
Але моделювання природи — це загалом дуже складна задача.
Мене звуть Victoria Lipinska, і сьогодні ми розглянемо один із алгоритмів,
який може зробити моделювання природи можливим на квантовому комп'ютері.
Почнімо з прикладу й розглянемо кофеїн.
Це проста молекула.
Щоб представити енергетичну конфігурацію лише однієї молекули кофеїну,
нам знадобиться приблизно десять у ступені 48 бітів.
Це десятка з 48 нулями —
приблизно 10% від кількості атомів у Землі.
І далі стає ще гірше.
Якщо маєш 125 орбіталей і хочеш зберегти всі можливі
конфігурації, тобі потрібно більше пам'яті
в класичному комп'ютері, ніж є атомів у Всесвіті.
Це неможливо представити на суперкомп'ютерах.
Проте для квантових комп'ютерів є надія:
вони від природи добре підходять для моделювання природи.
Для молекули кофеїну це означало б представлення
системи за допомогою 160 qubits.
Це звучить значно більш реалістично.
Було запропоновано різноманітні квантові алгоритми, що дозволяють
менш потужним квантовим комп'ютерам евристично моделювати природу.
Знайомся: варіаційний квантовий солвер власних значень, або VQE.
VQE — це алгоритм, що виконується частково на квантовому,
а частково на класичному комп'ютері.
Він дозволяє знаходити значення, що розв'язують задану задачу оптимізації.
VQE тісно пов'язаний з іншими методами, що включають
варіацію параметрів, наприклад квантовий апроксимаційний алгоритм оптимізації.
Визначити застосування VQE у своїй галузі чи дослідженнях —
це свого роду мистецтво, але є загальні орієнтири.
Загалом VQE застосовується до задач, які можна звести
до задачі оптимізації з неперервними змінними.
Це типово, наприклад, для більшості квантової хімії.
Дуже часто в хімії нас цікавить основний стан.
Основний стан — це стан системи з найнижчою енергією.
Щоб знайти енергію основного стану, VQE досліджує
енергію для різних конфігурацій системи
і шукає конфігурацію з найнижчою енергією.
На верхньому рівні VQE приймає опис квантової системи
і шукає найнижчу енергію.
Він робить це, варіюючи конфігурацію системи.
На початку нам потрібно ввести відповідний опис системи,
зрозумілий квантовому комп'ютеру, і набір параметрів, що її описують —
вони будуть оптимізовані.
Квантова частина
алгоритму готує систему в стані,
описаному заданим набором параметрів, і обчислює енергію.
Тоді як класична частина відповідає
за оптимізацію цих параметрів на кожному кроці.
Цей квантово-класичний процес повторюється,
поки ми не досягнемо найнижчої енергії.
Тепер заглянемо під капот і подивимося, що там відбувається.
Енергетична конфігурація зазвичай описується Гамільтоніаном —
і, як правило, це дуже велика матриця.
В алгебрі, щоб знайти найменше власне значення матриці,
що відповідає найнижчій енергії системи,
ми б просто виконали розклад за сингулярними значеннями.
Однак матриці, з якими ми будемо працювати, є експоненційно великими,
і розв'язати це алгебраїчно — експоненційно складна задача.
Цей Гамільтоніан потрібно представити у формі,
зрозумілій квантовому комп'ютеру.
Тобто перекласти з мови хімії на мову квантових обчислень.
Але не хвилюйся щодо деталей.
Зрештою, існують програмовані способи перекладу Гамільтоніана, що зазвичай
використовується в хімії, у Гамільтоніан, зрозумілий квантовому комп'ютеру.
Потім ми вводимо цей
Гамільтоніан разом із circuit, який ми називаємо варіаційною формою.
Вибір варіаційної форми — це теж свого роду мистецтво.
Знову ж таки,
вона представляє наше найкраще припущення про те, яким може бути квантовий стан системи.
Цей варіаційний circuit параметризований набором параметрів тета,
і ми також вводимо початковий вибір цих параметрів.
На основі цього квантова частина VQE:
готує референсний стан, наприклад нульовий стан;
використовує параметризований quantum circuit, варіаційну форму, щоб підготувати квантовий
стан для початкового вгадування параметрів на квантовому комп'ютері; і оцінює
енергію, що відповідає стану, обчисленому через Гамільтоніан.
Ця оцінка енергії потім передається
до класичного оптимізатора, який знаходить новий набір параметрів.
Параметри знову повертаються до квантового солвера,
і весь процес повторюється.
Квантовий комп'ютер знаходить нову оцінку енергії,
класичний оптимізатор знаходить новий набір параметрів — і так далі.
Ми повторюємо цей процес, поки розв'язок не зійдеться.
Тобто поки різниця між результатами на сусідніх кроках не стане достатньо малою
для наших потреб.
Зрештою алгоритм повертає цю мінімізовану енергію.
Чудово, це вже добре.
Але можеш запитати: звідки ми знаємо, що це справді працює
і що ми випадково не знайдемо енергію нижчу за ту, що шукаємо?
Це чудове питання.
Виявляється, ми ніколи не можемо отримати оцінку енергії, що є нижчою.
Це завдяки тому, що ми називаємо варіаційним принципом.
Варіаційний принцип стверджує, що найбільша нижня
межа енергії системи завжди є її
найнижчою енергією, що відповідає основному стану.
Це означає, що енергія, обчислена для будь-якого іншого стану системи,
завжди буде більшою за найнижчу енергію.
Тому з VQE ми ніколи не отримаємо значення,
нижче за енергію основного стану.
Проте ми справді можемо зійтися до чогось
більшого за мінімум, який шукаємо.
Це часто називають метастабільним розв'язком —
виклик, який дослідники намагаються вирішити щодня.
VQE корисний тим, що використовує менш глибокі circuits
порівняно з іншими протоколами для оцінки енергії основного стану.
Це робить його придатним для сучасного квантового заліза.
У цьому відео ми побіжно ознайомилися з тим, що вміє VQE і як він побудований.
Але я раджу тобі дослідити Qiskit у цьому контексті.
Хоча ми ще лише на початку нашої квантової подорожі,
ти вже можеш знайти застосування цьому для задач, які намагаєшся розв'язати.
Мене звуть Victoria Lipinska, і це був огляд
алгоритму варіаційного квантового солвера власних значень.